well hold on
there's not a lolly in it I've not got a
lolly this is like a faulty packet
that is all all dip and no dab
[Music]
hello I'm Ed gamble James acaster here
and this is snack Wars for lad Bible
we're Lads and we read the Bible today
we are doing Posh food versus
quote-unquote normal food look we're big
fans of of snack Wars I said we should
go on and do Catherine verses and then
you know I gotta think of a joke on the
spot and I said Buckingham Palace
because Ed is um a millimeter posher
than me would you like to do the honors
thanks for help you
yes now Posh surely we saw this this bad
boy coming you can put the clutch on the
floor if you want what if you don't want
to because you have to hold it here
because the caviar is giving you
[Laughter]
cheers cheers
delicious
the pop of the sea I think the topping
to slid down hole for me and then I'll
just chewed the the the the little
Crumpet this is how uh not Posh you are
you you even eat it wrong it won't even
stay in your mouth for very long because
it's like this this mouth is not
sophisticated enough already straight to
the butt yeah now let's have the brawn
cocktail let's see if you eat this right
the first time
I'm trying to use the posture it won't
stay on the Posh Fork yeah doesn't like
it yeah
most objectively better no way
immediately oh no we're falling into our
rolls you're getting the Tang of the
sauce nice plump fools it's not a nice
plump prawn
you can tell they all used to know each
other is that a point H yeah caviar for
me all day long I can't even taste that
okay okay here we go
now we're talking we're in James's World
Eaton mess eaten mess and Angel Delight
Angel Delight that cream
and looks very last minute yes I feel
like the cream
um should have been whipped yeah yeah so
this isn't really it's not really this
is a neat and slop yes
that's something different actually oh
yeah yeah that's what they do when
lights go out
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's fine but we both had a mess before
and we know that the thicker the cream
the bigger the dream so like that wasn't
really yeah that wasn't a fair
representation of being a mess that's
thin cream small dream you want to
chewing my man
would you eat a mess that's
rank sorry that looks absolutely
disgusting bubbly that is not bubbly
you're gonna have to in the sidebar of
YouTube link to a doctor pimple popper
video
there's not much flavor to it at all is
it it really isn't I'm not getting any
bubbles or any butterscotch there no
there's a little cow with a Halo there
in the cloud
Dead all the ingredients are in the
cloud in heaven yeah and uh how's dead
little dead cowl there oh no
um next to the word uh maltodextrin
yeah I'd say the mess uh for this one oh
definitely the Angels deserve better
that's right here we go
okay I bet you love Lunchables I'm
excited about those yeah because I bet
you love building them and popping them
in your mouth like this talk me through
it what are you doing uh I've got meat
cheese meat and then I'm gonna go cheese
again but I'm gonna put the cheese at a
different angle yeah I've done the other
time because they're rectangles and you
get to you're not going cracker on top
[Music]
it's the driest thing I've ever tasting
that is I mean I'm trying to pick one up
and it's just shattered in my hand that
is insane yeah the cracker is letting
the team down not very bad
Bongiorno
do you want to tug that yes thank you
okay
why did we suddenly turn into like
gangsters
we love Bible man I mean interviewing in
here
that was happening we can't do that we'd
serve each other like that yeah lazy
Susan laughs
[Music]
there you go well Yep this one no no
because I was meant to be doing a flavor
collab with them and then they never got
back to me so they're about to regret
that
peanut butter and chocolate
of course is it it's been a long time
since I've had a Fab I don't think I've
ever had a Fab the thing is with me I'm
a chocolate Hound so all I want to do is
eat the top level off this and then just
leave the rest of the icy stuff that's
the problem when you have something
that's like three layers and they've
started with the most exciting layer
because then very quickly you're just
eating a normalized lolly that's
horrible this is so icy
I'm really cold Yeah well yeah yeah but
be surprised by that yeah shall we
oh that's cool as well look at that
can't resist the swirl
great taste 2020. it says easy to win
great taste in a year where no one can
taste anything
what we've got peanut butter and
chocolate yes the best combination for
the winner here we go
I've been having no that is so good I'm
in heaven with that cow
this is what the Angels should be eating
man this is absolutely amazing and
there's whole peanuts in it whole
peanuts in it that's a good stuff yeah
we're just gonna sit here and watch
James eat the rest of that tub now
okay final mouthful James I reckon yeah
yeah
does anyone else ever come on the show
I've been hobbied on is that eating too
much of the food
okay okay this the first time these two
things have ever been under the same
cloche sherbet Deb dabs and a box from
Harvey Nichols this is a classic example
of the Mandela effect because everyone
thinks it's cool Mandela loves these
Mandela love these yeah but like
everyone thinks it's dib dabs but
they're dip dabs oh yeah but everyone
thinks it's dib dabs it's not it's sort
of the battle of the Suites that could
be mistaken for drugs at airport
security yeah now so here's an
interesting thing that the packet says
here
but it says lemon flavored sherbet with
a strawberry flavored Lolly now I'm only
seeing sherbet here
where's my you've got a lolly in there
mate feel it gotta be right there's not
a lolly in it I've not got a lolly this
is like a faulty packet
that is just pure
because that is all all dip and no dab
what have we had so far that I can dip
into it
um a Fab
oh yeah I'll different Fab in this okay
so we're going with a new fabulous
instead because like
parrot really screwed me over on that
one now
I'm actually down quite yeah of course
you are this is your dream yeah
that's a lot of sherbet there man
everything okay buddy
that's delicious that's I'm going in for
another one of them one of the issues
with circus Delight yeah I always find
yeah is they have different flavors but
then they're covered in so much sugar
that you can't even see the different
colors
happiness
that's the issue
this is the best thing of the day
no it's not in that I saw that guy
didn't want to say anything
um I'm going for the the hip Fab I'm
going for the Harvey Nichols Turkish
delight because I think the box is
absolutely delightful thing about the uh
surprise nature of uh snack Wars is as a
type 1 diabetic when you see the Turkish
delight and sherbet appearing you do
have to go in for a double dip dab of
insulence I mean
I feel like I'm gonna need some of that
as well you know no one asks you to do
that right
the the gods of entertainment did
[Laughter]
food one
good yeah yeah there's a reason why the
price is higher there I guess so that's
reassuring all of the Posh food
delicious but all of its opponents I
would you know on the whole happily as
well I'll have to eat I think a lot of
these things were underdogs compared to
their opponents so I think fans of the
dip dab might be happy to hear
there was a draw against Turkish delight
yeah sure you know Texas delight's been
top of the league for about 300 years
since Narnia times yeah imagine if it
was that
finds your depth up a lot of people
think it's called dip that but that's
not true when you get started he's just
with respect you lolly you've got a real
Edmond from Narnia Vibes here I think I
think so I think I could have been
betraying your friends I could easily
portray my friends for sweets yeah I'm
terminus
I can confirm
it's in all different forms of pastries
okay wait a minute wait a minute really
no hold on
[Applause]
laughs
you are you wearing different
foreign